go to our continuing special series
kindness 101 with steve hartman that's
where we share stories that are built
around themes of kindness and character
and the people who have mastered those
qualities this morning's lesson is
self-improvement steve and his kids
introduce us to a man who shows really
reminds us that you're never too old to
start something new
good morning i'm here with my daughter
merrill to celebrate the most important
teacher you have you that's right we're
talking about self-improvement emmett
you want to take a stab at defining this
one i know it's a toughy
self-improvement is improving yourself
genius
he gets that from me you know
i'm curious have you guys ever tried to
improve something about yourself and
struggled
trying to think do you have any ideas oh
i have plenty ideas
spit them out but this is
self-improvement not dad improvement
how about you meryl
it was
hard getting to have a lot of friends
i'm thinking more about just ways you
want to make yourself better oh i was
not done okay and
it's kind of just like sometimes i raise
my voice at my friends and maybe you
could start by not interrupting her
i agree
okay
yeah self-improvement can be harder than
it sounds which is why it's helpful to
have motivation
and today i have that for you a story
pulled from our archive of the most
inspiring americans this one the perfect
role model for self-improvement
inside a single wide in cookson oklahoma
a tortured soul lives alone
it's a hard life let me tell you
everybody you ain't never lived hard and
you'd
go through what i've been through this
is me ed bray served in world war ii he
was at normandy on d-day has two purple
hearts and more than a dozen other
medals
but to this day he still can't even read
what they're for
not because it's too painful victory
bakery but because he simply can't
read you know what that word is
e-u-r-o-p-e
yeah
the toughest thing that ever happened to
me in my life is not being able to read
he said you're at normandy though yes
illiteracy can be that damning i've
covered this up for 80 years
nobody in this town knows i can't read
until he retired ed worked a civilian
job at an air force base refueling
planes a co-worker helped him with the
forms and what not at home his wife
covered for him for 62 years until she
died in 09. put you guys some coffee on
today ed manage is ok but the soldier in
him still refuses to surrender i wanted
to read one book i don't care if it's
about mickey mouse
i want to read one book
before i die
over the years ed says many people have
tried to school him but invariably
either the teacher or the student would
get frustrated and give up
then a few months ago a friend suggested
he see a professor of reading education
here at oklahoma's northeastern state
university he told me i was wasting my
time
and i said well we'll just sit and chat
a couple times a week is that okay very
good toby thompson says eventually their
weekly talks gave way to flash cards and
everything started clicking four he got
pretty good at the sight words one catch
up but the real breakthrough came when
at the age of 89 ed read this book about
george washington
it gave me goose bumps and it still does
to power a car
he read three more shortly after
each one good job the same dramatic
ending do you ever think you'd read that
each one the same lesson for anyone
considering self-improvement
get in there and learn baby
now
because you ain't gonna learn in that
pine box just learn to read and already
a poet and that's the truth
ten years later the one thing no one's
been able to read is ed's obituary he's
still with us and he's with us hello ed
i'm ready baby okay
you went around and talked to a lot of
schools after our story what was your
message to them
telling them children to read books and
put them phones away that's good advice
this telephone they got today was the
worst invention we've ever made
they're a pain
i can't already run my own
um
do you think you inspired other people
to read oh yeah yes i've got boxes and
boxes of letters from all over the world
oh how old are you now
99 can you believe you made it that long
no i don't know what god's got me living
for
i do what you're reading to inspire
other people ed
thank you guys for me thank you so much
you made my day today
so that's class for today
hopefully meeting ed will inspire a
better you
we'll see you next time until then stay
kind
[Music]
oh man great it's full of wisdom yeah
yeah
listen he said get in there and learn
baby because you ain't gonna learn it in
a pine box that is as real as it gets
yeah yeah if you want to learn something
do it now yeah because time is ticking
it is time is ticking it's kindness 101.
you believe he's not 100. he might be
it'd be kindness 101 and he'll be 101.
we'll revisit him in two more years i
said that during the break i know i
stole it from you
i thought i'll just take that i'd
self-improve we call it through
acquisition
thank you for that kindness